Argentina, Argentina, ¿Qué haríamos en
VisualPolitik sin la Argentina?
De ser el granero del mundo, un potente exportador
de carne y tener muchísimas reservas de gas,
petróleo y litio; a estar permanentemente
sumergido en un bucle de constantes problemas
financieros y económicos…
Es la eterna contradicción argentina.
Que os contemos que el país está a punto
de quebrar, ya no es una novedad, ¿verdad?
Y, sin embargo…
Así estamos.
N1(10 de mayo de 2023: ​​Argentina se
arruina por intentar frenar el colapso total
de su moneda.
El Banco Central tiene más pasivos que activos
en su balance.
Bloomberg)
N2(15 de febrero de 2023: Dos de cada tres
niños en Argentina son pobres o están privados
de derechos básicos.
Unicef)
N3(31 de marzo de 2023: Argentina suma en
2022 un millón de nuevos pobres, hasta el
39,2% de la población.
El País)
Pues bien, en medio de semejante contexto,
este pasado 13 de agosto se han celebrado
las Primarias Abiertas, Simultáneas y Obligatorias
(PASO), una especie de elecciones donde todas
las fuerzas políticas están obligadas a
participar para elegir o ratificar a sus candidatos.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Sus resultados han sido un auténtico bombazo.
Los argentinos han dicho basta.
(“Hemos logrado construir esta alternativa
competitiva que no solo dará fin al kirchnerismo,
sino que además dará fin a la casta política
parasitaria, chorra e inutil que hunde este
país.)
Javier Milei, el libertario outsider que llegó
a la política argentina en 2019 ha ganado,
contra todo pronóstico, estas particulares
elecciones.
“Invito a los argentinos a sumarse a la
revolución liberal que va a hacer que en
35 años Argentina vuelva a ser una potencia
mundial.
Muchas gracias y ¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!
¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!)
Tal y como podéis ver, se ha convertido no
solo en el candidato más votado individualmente,
sino que con más del 30% de los votos se
ha puesto por delante del resto de fuerzas
políticas.
(“Hoy nos hemos puesto de pie para decirle
basta al modelo de la decadencia.
Hoy dimos el primer paso para la reconstrucción
de la Argentina”.
)
Y eso no es todo, tras años y años de hegemonía
política, ahora el peronismo parece herido
de muerte.
Acaba de obtener uno de sus peores resultados
electorales de toda la historia.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué?
¿Qué explica su debacle?
¿Por qué el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
se hizo tan impopular?
¿Qué puede suponer este maremoto político
para la Argentina?
¿Se convertirá acaso Javier Milei en el
nuevo presidente de la república?
Queridos amigos, amigas, vamos a ver todas
las respuestas y, en un próximo vídeo aquí
en VisualPolitik, veremos también qué quiere
exactamente esté nuevo león político para
la Argentina.
Así que…
Arranquemos.
Argentina no solo ha sido el país de las
crisis.
Durante años también fue el país bandera
de la inestabilidad política.
Entre los años 1930 y 1976 el país vivió
ni más ni menos que 6 golpes de Estado…
Digamos que en aquellos tiempos los militares
tenían poca paciencia.
En promedio, los argentinos sufrían un golpe
de Estado cada 2.800 días.
Sin embargo, esta situación cambió por completo
a partir de 1983, cuando los militares se
vieron obligados a abandonar el ejecutivo
tras la derrota de las Malvinas.
(La llegada de la democracia supuso retomar
las garantías constitucionales más elementales.
Atrás quedaron los tiempos de la censura
y la represión.
Sin embargo, aunque, el primer presidente
electo en esta nueva etapa democrática, Raúl
Ricardo Alfonsín, tuvo bastante éxito a
la hora de reconstruir las instituciones políticas,
fue un desastre económico.
En 1989, cuando dejó el poder, el país registraba
una inflación anual de más del 4.900%)
Claro que luego llegó la remontada.
Ya os lo hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik,
durante la presidencia de Carlos Menem entre
1989 y 1999, la economía argentina despegó
como un cohete…
Hasta que la eterna adicción argentina al
gasto público volvió a mandar todo al carajo.
En 2001 todo se vino abajo.
El presidente De la Rúa tuvo que dimitir,
la economía argentina entró en default y
en la calle se produjo una ola de indignación
popular al compás de un grito:
“Que se vayan todos”.
Y sí, aquí también se asaltó el Congreso.
Luego, en las siguientes elecciones, en las
del 2003, el candidato más votado en primera
vuelta fue de nuevo Carlos Ménem, pero sin
opciones reales de lograr la victoria, decidió
no presentarse a la segunda vuelta.
Néstor Kirchner asumió el timón de mando.
Comenzó entonces la era del Kirchnerismo.
Desde entonces han pasado más de 20 años,
de los cuales tan solo 4 han tenido un gobierno
no peronista.
Nos referimos, por supuesto, al de Mauricio
Macri entre 2015 y 2019.
En el resto del tiempo el peronismo-kirchnerismo
ha sido hegemónico.
En 2011, Cristina Fernández de Kirchner logró
incluso la reelección con el 54% de los votos
en primera vuelta.
La suya se convirtió en la tercera candidatura
con más apoyo electoral de toda la historia
argentina.
El peronismo kirchnerista por sí mismo se
había convertido en todo un imperio.
Y en 2019, tras la etapa de Mauricio Macri,
el primer líder democrático no peronista
en completar su mandato en los últimos 90
años, la coalición peronista-Kirchnerista
El Frente de Todos, arrasó.
Los argentinos les echaban de menos.
Sin embargo, este mandato se hizo tan cuesta
arriba que todo ese capital y poder político
empezó a evaporarse.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué explica exactamente
la debacle que está sufriendo el peronismo?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1(CFK Y LA DEBACLE PERONISTA)
Cristina Fernández de Kirchner, para bien
o quizás, sobre todo, para mal, ha supuesto
un antes y un después para la política argentina.
Tras la muerte de su esposo en octubre del
2010, CFK se hizo con las riendas del país
y desde entonces se ha convertido en uno de
los personajes políticos más controvertidos
no solo de Argentina, sino también de toda
América Latina y quizás de todo el mundo.
Hablamos de una líder política que nunca
ha dejado de estar en el candelero y que siempre
ha hecho todo lo posible por manejar los hilos
del poder.
Por ejemplo, en 2019 apostó por que Alberto
Fernández, un antiguo colaborador suyo y
uno de los peronistas más críticos con su
figura, fuese el candidato a la presidencia
mientras ella hacía y deshacía desde la
vicepresidencia.
Esa al menos era su intención.
Yo la escuchaba, y me dijo
Yo llegue a la conclusión de que
el candidato tienes que ser vos
Me dijo yo voy a ser
tu candidato a vicepresidenta
y ahí entendí menos
Y eso que hablamos de un tipo que durante
años estuvo repitiendo acusaciones como esta:
una de las cosas que más criticó a
Cristina es el modo en que ha maltratado
a la justicia y el maltrato a la
justicia supone también el maltrato a
los fiscales
Con casi 13 millones de votos, el peronismo
arrasó.
Los argentinos le dieron su confianza a este
particular tándem y ni siquiera hizo falta
una segunda vuelta.
Empezó entonces una de las legislaturas más
complicadas y duras que se recuerdan.
El día 10 de diciembre de 2019 Alberto Fernández
se convirtió en presidente.
La idea era que Alberto contribuyera a moderar
el peronismo.
Y lo cierto es que su mandato comenzó con
una altísima tasa de popularidad.
Sin embargo, la primera tormenta no tardaría
en estallar.
(Apenas tres meses después de alcanzar la
Casa Rosada, se desató la pandemia de la
Covid-19.
El gobierno argentino apostó entonces por
establecer una de las cuarentenas más largas
de todo el mundo.
En un primer momento, en plena cuarentena,
el Índice de Confianza en el gobierno se
disparó y batió su mejor registro en 15
años.
Sin embargo, este sentimiento no tardó en
darse la vuelta.
Comenzó entonces una caída libre que ha
llegado hasta nuestros días.)
Por supuesto, la pandemia y la aplicación
de una cuarentena larguísima hicieron mella
en la economía.
Y a eso le tenemos que sumar noticias como
esta:
N4(Impacto político por la foto que muestra
a Alberto Fernández de festejo en Olivos
en plena cuarentena.
La Nación)
El resultado es que en 2021 el gobierno estaba
ya, políticamente hablando, contra las cuerdas,
prácticamente al límite.
Alberto Fernández era menos popular que un
examen sorpresa un lunes a primera hora.
El mito popular del peronismo de repente se
estaba esfumando.
Y cuando llegaron las elecciones legislativas
ya os podéis imaginar lo que ocurrió:
El oficialismo se dio un señor tortazo.
Fue una catástrofe electoral, sobre todo
porque incluso en importantes bastiones peronistas
del interior del país, el apoyo al Frente
de Todos, la gran coalición oficialista,
hizo aguas.
Y lo más importante, era el preámbulo de
lo que estaba por venir.
Entre otras cosas porque en política cuando
ganas y gobiernas es muy fácil hacer amigos,
pero cuando pierdes…
Entonces los problemas y las puñaladas se
multiplican.
Que es exactamente lo que ocurrió.
La propia vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández
hizo pública una carta cargando toda la responsabilidad
sobre el presidente:
C1(“Señalé que creía que se estaba llevando
a cabo una política de ajuste fiscal equivocada
que estaba impactando negativamente en la
actividad económica y, por lo tanto, en el
conjunto de la sociedad y que, indudablemente,
esto iba a tener consecuencias electorales.
No lo dije una vez…
me cansé de decirlo… y no solo al presidente
de la Nación.
La respuesta siempre fue que no era así,
que estaba equivocada y que, de acuerdo a
las encuestas, íbamos a ganar “muy bien”
las elecciones.”
Carta Pública de CFK – 16 de septiembre
de 2021)
Ese fue un punto de no retorno.
A partir de ahí el gobierno se rompió por
completo y comenzó un sálvese quien pueda:
de repente vimos a ministros criticar al propio
gobierno, a la señora K airear por las cuatro
esquinas lo desastroso que era Fernández
y a todo el kirchnerismo en bloque presionando
para cambiar la política económica.
La situación llegó a tal punto, que, en
marzo de 2022, cuando el ministro de Economía,
Martín Guzmán, logro alcanzar un acuerdo
con el FMI para reestructurar la deuda argentina,
parte de los diputados kirchneristas votaron
en contra en el Congreso.
Lo que puso las conversaciones con el FMI
al borde del abismo.
Amigos, la lucha fratricida no solo hizo que
Fernández necesitara votos de la oposición,
sino que terminó con la dimisión del propio
ministro de Economía, y la implosión total
del gobierno y del peronismo.
Las cosas estaban tan mal que Alberto y Cristina
probaron una solución de última hora, una
última bala.
Con el gobierno al borde del default y la
inflación por las nubes, acordaron poner
a Sergio Massa, un influyente político y
entonces presidente de la Cámara de Diputados,
al frente del Ministerio de Economía.
Y no solo eso.
Le dieron también el Ministerio de la producción
y el Ministerio de Agricultora.
Es decir, básicamente en un momento en el
que la economía lo era todo, le dieron las
llaves del gobierno…
¿El resultado?
No cambió nada.
Las cosas siguieron de mal en peor.
Y ojo porque la perspectiva del gobierno,
al menos públicamente, es muy diferente.
Según ellos, el problema, el auténtico problema
de Argentina, es que el país ha ido demasiado
bien.
Sí, sí, demasiado bien, tal cual como lo
escucháis.
estamos tratando de acumular reservas en un
momento en que tenemos una demanda de
dólares muy grandes porque la economía
No para de crecer el problema que
tenemos Es que la economía crece mucho
la gente percibe que ellos en su
vida individual están mejor pero que
todo el mundo está mal o que todas las
situaciones está mal esto es una
construcción no es algo que tiene que
ver con la vida con la vida cotidiana
Lo que, por supuesto, contrasta por completo
con la realidad social.
Para que os hagáis una idea las cosas están
tan mal que decir hoy por hoy que Argentina
es un país deprimido ya no es ninguna exageración.
La que fuera una de las mayores potencias
mundiales a principios del siglo XX, hoy lucha
por superar por no quedarse muy atrás de
países como Bulgaria o Rumanía.
Este país sigue batiendo récords y 1 de
cada 4 personas tiene ya síntomas de ansiedad
y depresión.
Evidentemente, la mala situación económica
y profesional tiene mucho que ver con todo
esto.
Por mucho que el gobierno insista en decir
lo contrario.
Es decir, teníamos sobre la mesa una interminable
crisis económica, un presidente tremendamente
impopular, un oficialismo roto en bandos que
se odian y un gobierno que encima parecía
vivir en otro planeta.
Y mi pregunta es, ¿pensáis que ahí se acaba
todo?
Pues no podéis estar más equivocados.
Para colmo, en diciembre de 2022 la justicia
dictó sentencia sobre una de las tantas causas
de corrupción que tiene abiertas Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner.
La condenaron de forma firme.
(VIDEO 8)
condenar a Cristina Elizabeth Fernández
de Kirchner a la pena de seis años de
prisión e
inhabilitación especial perpetua para
ejercer cargos públicos)
Y claro, con semejante bagaje no nos puede
sorprender que el peronismo se haya hundido.
El desastre ha sido colosal incluso para los
cánones de la política argentina.
De hecho, teniendo en cuenta todos los acontecimientos,
¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Que el peronismo todavía siga cosechando
casi el 30% de los votos resulta sorprendente.
Casi, caso incomprensible.
Pero, aun así, su tercer puesto en las PASO
es el fiel reflejo de todo lo que ha pasado.
Claro que el hundimiento del peronismo no
solo se explica por sus propios errores.
En este caso, la oposición también ha tenido
mucho que ver.
Atentos.
T2 (UNA OPOSICIÓN MUCHO MÁS COMBATIVA)
Amigos, pese al desastre electoral de 2019,
cuando los peronistas se hicieron de nuevo
con el timón del país, “Cambiemos”,
la plataforma que había aupado a Mauricio
Macri, no se disolvió ni se fragmentó.
Cambio su nombre a Juntos por el Cambio y
pese a muchas batallas internas continuó
unida.
Eso fue algo que les permitió hacer frente
al gobierno con mucha más fuerza.
Lo que fue clave para su victoria en las últimas
legislativas de 2021.
Por primera vez en mucho tiempo la alternativa
al peronismo no estaba dividida.
A las primarias de 2023 llegaron, además,
con dos propuestas muy diferentes: por un
lado, Horacio Rodríguez Larreta, que venía
de sumar ocho años al frente de la jefatura
de gobierno de la Ciudad de Buenos Aires.
Larreta tiene un perfil moderado y se ha mostrado
más abierto a dialogar con el peronismo para
buscar espacios comunes, lo que le valió
el mote de “Paloma”.
Por otro lado, estaba Patricia Bullrich, exministra
de seguridad de Mauricio Macri y una candidata
con muchos menos problemas a la hora de pegarse
con los sindicatos y el kirchnerismo.
Bullrich era el “Halcon” y ahora las PASO
han decidido que sea la candidata de Juntos
por el Cambio.
Claro que al final no fue ella ni tampoco
su formación política los grandes protagonistas
de las PASO.
El protagonista y el gran triunfador ha sido
sin duda Javier Milei, un economista outsider,
que ha convertido su campaña en una enorme
arenga no ya contra el gobierno sino contra
todo el modelo político de la Argentina.
(Yo no me metí en esto para estar guiando
corderos, yo me metía acaba para despertar
leones.
¡Quiero escucharlos rugir!
¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!)
(Cuando la Argentina entró en el siglo XX,
era el país más rico del mundo.
Argentina tenía una de las monedas más sólidas
del mundo.
Millones de inmigrantes se agolpaban ante
nuestras costas para poder tener la chanza
de tener un futuro mejor.
Éramos la envidia del mundo.
Sin embargo, en un momento la clase política
decidió que la riqueza de los argentinos
no podía estar en manos de los argentinos
sino que tenía que estar en las manos de
ellos.)
Milei promete acabar de raíz con todos los
males económicos de la Argentina.
Habla de dolarizar la economía, suprimir
gran parte del estado, bajar los impuestos
y en, definitiva, romper con el que ha sido
el modelo económico-político de la Argentina
durante los últimos 70, 80 o, incluso, 90
años.
no les molesta pedir guita para el déficit
fiscal y si les jode de
repente tener que ir a buscar para dolarizar
la economía y terminar con la inflación,
te das cuenta que es un
modelo de saqueo te das cuenta que son un
conjunto de delincuentes hijos de [ __
Con un programa agresivo y tremendamente ambicioso,
prácticamente revolucionario, logró un enorme
triunfo.
A penas nadie lo vio venir, pero Milei, se
hizo con más del 30% de los votos, ganó
en 16 provincias y se impuso tanto en alguno
de los barrios más populares como en los
pueblos más prósperos de la Argentina.
Sin embargo, un momento, porque Milei todavía
no es presidente.
Sí, ahora ya podemos hablar de él como una
candidatura favorita, pero todavía queda
carrera por delante.
Por un lado, Milei tendrá que expandir su
techo electoral.
Para ser presidente necesita conseguir más
votos.
Las PASO han dejado el mapa político muy
abierto.
Solo 2,8 puntos separan a las 3 grandes formaciones
políticas.
Y aquí se dan dos circunstancias contrapuestas:
por un lado, el perfil histriónico de Milei
puede no encajar mucho con el electorado que
busca un cambio pero no una revolución - que
sorprendentemente sigue siendo muy grande.
De hecho, la abstención fue muy alta, casi
un tercio del electorado se quedó en casa.
Y el juego en octubre puede ser algo diferente.
Recordad que en Argentina el voto es obligatorio
y que la participación suele superar el 80%,
más de 11 puntos más de la participación
que hemos visto en esta especie de pre-elecciones.
Entre 10 y 13 puntos más, que en un escenario
tan igualado a tercios pueden cambiarlo todo.
Pero, por otra parte, qué demonios, Milei
ha ganado las PASO.
Y en política la victoria llama a victoria.
A partir de hoy el voto a este candidato ya
es un voto perfectamente útil.
“Invito a los argentinos a sumarse a la
revolución liberal que va a hacer que en
35 años Argentina vuelva a ser una potencia
mundial.
Muchas gracias y ¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!
¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!)
Pero, incluso de llegar a la presidencia,
se enfrentaría a otro importante problema:
Y es que, veréis, en Argentina, la Cámara
de Diputados renueva cada dos años la mitad
de sus miembros, y el Senado solo se renueva
por tercios.
Es decir, un gobierno que llegue desde 0 al
poder, sin bloques previos en el parlamento,
lo tendría muy difícil para hacer cambios
importantes.
Sea como sea, lo que está claro es que Argentina
se enfrenta sí o sí a un cambio sísmico.
Los argentinos han dicho basta.
Por primera vez el peronismo se ha hundido
y por primera vez la alternativa es claramente
mayoritaria.
De una forma u otra, todo apunta a que Argentina
va a cambiar.
Pero de todo eso hablaremos en un próximo
vídeo.
Ahora la pregunta es: ¿será este el final
del peronismo?
¿Quién se hará finalmente con la presidencia?
¿Creéis que Argentina logrará salir adelante?
¿Podrán llegar las banderas libertarias
a la Casa Rosada?...
Y si nos estás viendo desde el país gaucho,
¿a qué candidato apoyas?
Dejadnos vuestras opiniones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.